didn't set myself up for a failure on  this one aaron please relax  a bear that was knoxville's idea that  was not my idea  it was great footage  i i got to get out of this thing  listen you're putting honey on me and  salmon  yeah what are you doing  [Music]  oh my god you asked for that with  wearing that shirt that shirt is so  perfect so many books so little time  so good  the bear when we were filming it though  i was like this is getting too gnarly  like did you see it try to call it yeah  the best is like it almost bites his  hand it almost bites his hand and we're  like trying to make the judgment do we  call it no because it right away then  the bear went for his penis  oh let's see what happens  [Applause]  [Music]  you